but there's also plenty of room by the
way for hate good old-fashioned bigotry
as well
and
you want to find it
you need to look no further of course
than the modern republican party
this week republican senator roger
marshall from the state of kansas
announced that he's contemplating
blocking
an effort
a bipartisan effort in the senate
to fund school lunch programs across the
united states because
he's worried the biden administration
might use this as an opportunity
to not let states discriminate
against lgbtq
let me read his statement as to why he's
currently on the fence
about feeding kids lunches at school
here he is
i'm just afraid that schools in kansas
won't have school lunches because of
this administration's radical view on
transgender issues and i'm afraid that
they're going to raid the school lunch
program over that issue
now seems a little confusing i
understand
here is what this idiot is confusing
mr marshall senator martial i'll give
him that title senator marshall
believes that the usda's guidance
on who can receive funding which is of
course you got to make sure you do not
allow discrimination and bullying of
lgbtq youth in your school if you do
that if we find out you are in violation
we will take away your money the usda
says but only if you're receiving
federal money
for nutritional programs
it does not apply
to the school lunch
program
so senator marshall isn't even talking
about the right
thing
but it doesn't matter right he didn't
take the five seconds that it would take
to understand that he has confused two
completely separate issues all he knows
is hey schools in kansas may be bullying
lgbtq kids and we don't want to lose our
lunches so nobody gets a lunch
you're gonna tank
this whole effort a bipartisan effort by
the way that they're trying to ram
through quickly which is why you only
need one objection to stall it
they're trying to ram it through before
june 30th when the funding for the
current program expires
so senator marshall i guess would rather
see all kids go hungry
than have to see school districts not
allow
lgbtq youth to be bullied
in school
right let's just make everybody go
hungry
because we want to see kids
get
bullied
and again
it's all actually because he doesn't
even understand that he has confused two
completely separate issues
hmm
what a party right
listen we got to take another quick
break but if you want even more from me
follow me across social media twitter
facebook instagram at farron balanced
and you can find me on my youtube
channels at youtube.com slash the ring
of fire youtube.com fair and balanced
i'm also the host of the weekly ring of
fire podcast which you can find online
at rofpodcast.com
this is the david pakman show and we'll
be right back with more